it is very challenging and the reason it
is so challenging now is you know when
you're younger It's relatively easy
because you're just caring for a child
aren't you but then that child grows up
and gets bigger and heavier
um and then you're caring for an adult
and the whole system changes then and
myself you know I'm 30 years older than
I was when I first started nearly 40
years older and my health needs I have
them as well so that means it makes it
really extremely difficult to carefully
physically you know because it requires
a lot of moving and handling
lifting and moving you know on the bed
to change him get him dressed get them
washed things like that and I'm finding
that really really difficult at the
moment my husband is self-employed so he
can't get time off because if he does
get time off to help me with Lee then he
doesn't get paid
and that's always very difficult you
know the cost of living's going up isn't
it energy bills are rising we do
struggle with that